I think we should just get started Let's
uh bid Welcome to our final speaker Sor
chai thank you very much for uh staying
around until to the very last talk I'm
sorai today I will tell you more about
the problem called KH connected spanning
subgraph and how to approximate it using
fast LP solver this is Joy work
with
and okay so let's Jump Right In um so
let me first Define the problem K
connected spaning subgraph uh first of
all gra a graph is k h connected if it
remains connected after removing uh K
minus one edges or like the minan cut is
at least K so that's what I mean by K
connected and the problem definition is
the following uh give you a underated
graph and a cost function on each Edge
and output we need to compute the mean
cost uh K connector spanning subgraph
meaning that uh comput a subgraph that
is spanning that contain all the nodes
and also computer has to be K connected
and I want to minimize the
cost for this problem uh when K is equal
to one is is kind of easy to solve right
because um what a connected is a tree so
this is minimum spanning threee
problem but uh the problem comes apx art
as soon as K is at least two even on the
bounded graph abouted degree graph and
Bally cost function and the best known
approximation for this problem is two uh
which is known very long ago and the KH
connected spinning sub graph is a
special case of the survivable network
design problem which is a much broader
class um so in terms of the complexity
of this problem uh for the case of VAR
is uh small K let's say for two CSS you
can do three approximation in the
quadratic time and for General K you can
do also uh two approximation in mnk or
you can do something like 2K minus one
approximation in qu take time and so on
but the and also there's a algorithm by
a gen that give like two approximation
that solve much broader class not not
just a k um and today uh I will tell you
more about the the the new result in
this area meaning that uh we can show
that uh you can give two plus Epsilon
approximation if you in in nearly linear
time if you can output only the estimate
output the value but if you want to
Output the solution uh it we need some
more time uh addition like n to the 1.5
five time K Square over S1 Square to get
the the integral solution and the key uh
main main main technique is that we just
solve the lp solve the lp in nearly
linear time and then we do the rounding
um so let me uh talk about how to solve
LP uh for this problem
and okay so here is the uh LP
formulation for K KSS problem so I want
to minimize the uh the sum of the cost
on the on the variable XE and then we
want to select uh each Edge uh such that
the for each cut it cover at least K
amount for per cut and then there's a
restriction that you cannot pick more
than one one Edge so there's an upper
limit on the box constraint here and for
the purpose of this talk when uh when I
say cut here I mean the set of edges in
inste of set of noes so for example when
I say cut AB it means literally just two
edges
there and how fast can we solve this K
kcss LP um you can solve it in uh MN
Time s Square by flasher really long ago
and it turns out that if you want to
solve the there's a if you want there's
a slightly easier problem which is
called a KSM if you can remove the bo
constraint meaning that if you can
select multiple edges then this problem
is called KSM K connected spaning multi
subgraph and the similar LP can be
solved uh
efficiently um and the LP uh is exactly
the same except that you don't have B
constraint and uh the
key recent work by cheul and condr give
this uh say that that this particular LP
can be Sol in nearly linear
time however the framework cannot handle
the B constraint and the the key
contribution of this work is basically
we show that well their framework can
actually be extended and solve this B
constraint that that's the main main uh
Main
message okay um now what are some
application of this how what is a use
useful uh utility of the applic lp
solware so we can use it to estimate the
optimal integral solution within Factor
two because of the integrality Gap is
two in this case and uh we can also use
this to get the integral solution that
is uh running time of this form of M xon
squ plus M 1.5 k
and square but the key approach here we
follow the standard template that also
even outlined in the in in the other
works that we use the we solve the uh KS
LP up to one paron accuracy
and we specify the lp solution using
some some form of graph comparation
theorem from Beno carer and we show that
the we can spfy the graph so that the
number edges is of the form K square and
Fon minus 2 uh to Theus two and then we
run the combinatory algorithm by Cooler
within on this support on the support of
spfy graph and and and hence we get this
this kind of running time but for today
I'm more interested I I want to focus on
how to solve the lp uh very LP server in
nearly linear time uh so so I want to
focus on this main
result now uh next I'm going to talk
talk about uh the the multipli update
framework and I I want to highlight the
key challenge that appear in in uh in in
handling the B constraint okay and look
at so okay I I know that everyone is
familiar with this framework I want to
uh phrase this in a language that uh
that that we know in a common language
here so let's talk let's take a look at
the cing lp the general cing LP that
minimiz the transport such a at least
one now you can uh one can think about
this as a uh very tall Matrix implicit
Matrix in a sense that the number Bros
can be exponentially really large and
all the entry is
positive so I want to solve this
covering LP and uh the standard
multic with update framework from G and
conoman says that well this you can
reduce this problem to solve a sequence
of the simpler problem which is called
the minan r problem and the Min row
problem is the following I give you a
weight Vector which is basically the
weight of each column and then the Min
low problem asks for the uh minimum row
such that the inner product between the
row of the Matrix and the weight is is
minimized so that's the mean r problem
and the key uh theorem is that well you
you can obtain the one Parton
approximate solution to this covering LP
by solving a sequence of this problem
for M log M over s squ
iterations
now the the proof itself is also uh not
very difficult I also uh wait okay I
also highly recommend you to check ombre
talk on the dynamic graph Workshop that
talk also the same LP topic and then he
provide elegant one slide proof of this
theorem uh but for for us today it's
only uh for us uh the goal is to compute
this fast enough so we will focus on
what is the minan r problem in know
setting and then how far can we solve it
any question on this
part no then okay um
good um next I'm going to uh give you
one example of how to use this framework
to how to do this framework to describe
the mean low problem of k e SM smlp
which mean that the K connected sping
multi subgraph so it's the same thing as
KSS LP but uh there's no bo constraint
okay and then you can write this uh
Matrix a as a cut and Edge incident
Matrix and uh what is the mean row
problem in this case so for example so
the cut incident metric you can see like
C1 represent one cut and then it
incident on which Edge and so on and the
minan row problem is the following that
I give you an edge uh I give the weight
function on each Edge right and then and
then ask for the minimizing row here uh
minimizer row here which correspond to
the minan card problem so basically if
you look at this LP and then you uh
forward uh look at this format of mean
roll problem then the the Oracle problem
here is the classic Global main card
problem however if you want to solve
this uh KSS LP you cannot quite it
cannot uh quite do that directly because
of the Annoying B constraint over there
that is that makes the problem not not
LP not Lally a p covering
LP if you want to do this in all setting
we need a p covering LP and then there's
a standard way to get around this Bo
constraints by adding the extra uh
inequalities also known as a n c
inequality which is a very generic
technique but to be specific for uh all
setting uh so we do the we we strengthen
the lp in the following way first
uh but look at the
cut uh like for each uh for each cut in
the strength uh we add the r we add the
following pick any uh subset of the
edges inside that cut of size at mostos
K and
uh we're going to because we want to
remove the the the B constraint we're
going to add the the constraint in a way
that uh we for the solution to pre-
purchas the set of
hsf by by already by by already F of
them will force the solution to to
prepurchase that so that the remaining
part you need to satisfy K minus F and I
do that for all the subset of size K
inside the the the set
F by and by doing that uh we can uh get
rid of the the upper B constraint
because the the the constraint here kind
of enforce you not to uh pick the the
larger ones and we can rewrite this uh
constraint in this form uh and we can
ask the same question uh what is uh
uh you can ask the same question now uh
what is the Oracle problem of this kind
of PE p version of this KS so now we can
write this in terms of the the cut fee
isent metrix where each row correspond
to a cut and a set of the free Edge when
I say free Edge it mean that the the the
free Edge set inside that cut so now
it's a cut and free Edge at incidental
and Edge Matrix right and it's a
standard fact that you can solve this is
enough to solve this a p covering
version and okay what is a minan r
problem
now uh it's also instructive to to take
a look by inspection what what would be
the the constraint Matrix of the this uh
extrem version of the lp so let's fix
the the cut uh uh uh fix some cut that
contain three edges for example so the
in the metrix a the cut incident Matrix
would look like this that have uh one
one one on the first three column and if
I add let's say the free Edge uh if I
add zero free Edge it means that I need
to satisfy K right so I get the First
Column that is one overk on on the first
uh first row and then in the next row I
could also make is a single edge free
when I make a single edge free meaning
that I don't need to worry about to
satisfy one of the edge and then I need
to uh satisfy less than K in K minus one
and so on and then this keep happening
for like one and also for all pair for
all two and so on okay now looking at
the the formula for the mean row problem
you just take look at this uh uh Matrix
a uh uh with adding the new constraint
and look at the the weight function of
is Edge right and minan roll problem
asks for uh minim minimizing the in
inner product between this constraint
Matrix and the the minimizing the the
role of the Matrix and inner product of
the row Matrix and the weight
right and then minan R problem turns out
to look like the following function that
you want to minimize or overall cut and
then each each cut you allow to kind of
ignore uh up to F edges and then F here
can be at most side of at most K minus
one and then you need to also normalize
by K minus F and here when I denote w s
it means the sum of the we inside the
set the upshot is
that uh
theide is that this is the new mean roll
problem in the kcss problem so we get
this uh uh this expression the which we
call the normalized free card
problem and notice that uh in the
version of KSM where we don't have the
bo constraint the minan row problem is
just simply A Min cut but now if you
have to deal with a B constraint the m r
problem become this uh normalized
version of the free Cut problem so the
after is that there's a technical
challenge that if you remove B con and
apply this uh multiplic update framework
on this covering LP then you get this uh
this this normalized three card
problem any uh question at this
point very
good now let's spend some time and
taking uh trying to understand what uh
this uh noral free Cut problem a little
bit more so what do we know anything
about in the literature uh so what do we
know so far
um so one one one thing to think about
is that look at this uh cut so you look
the nominator means that you can fix a
let's say fix a cut C right and then
denominator means that you can ignore up
to ks one edges so basically you should
ignore the the most expensive edges in
there but when you the more you can
ignore the less normalizing factor that
you have right and in other words you
can also write this problem and rewrite
it expression by the following way so
identify Lambda I to be the mean cut
which uh I edges being removed so we can
let's say you can remove I edges and
then this is the Lambda I I call this I
free mean cut okay now you can also
rewrite this expression to be uh uh the
mean roll problem to be like the minimum
between Lambda I over K minus uh K uh
minus I so
basically uh if if it's minimum between
the normal mean cut and normaliz by K or
you ignore one Ed but you normalize less
or up to the K minus one okay and how
fast can we solve this problem what is
the complexity so even is it even
polinomial time
solvable so this is a question to to
look at and so let's say let's let's
let's imagine that I want to compute
Lambda I how do I compute Lambda I right
so basically uh I can uh do the
following way that I can do like U and
choose I uh basically to compute I free
minan Cut the way one root Force way to
do is to uh select a uh look at a graph
remove I edges from the graph and
compute mean cut right and then you can
do that in choose it time and then you
get like Call of M cut
but I mean but if you need to do all
that then it's going to be like om M
actually
yeah then if you do do do op that this
is uh like would be exp exponentially
many call of me cut so this is not the
like the right strategy and it turns out
that uh Computing Lambda I is also known
as the connectivity interdiction problem
where uh it is known that you can
compute it in polinomial time and and to
the four and therefore if you plug in
this uh resolve by S clusen we can also
show that well you can solve this in kmn
to4 and that the technique there is
based on some cut enumeration
problem but if you but for all purpose
we need much faster than that and we
also need to be able to maintain this
cut as well so this seems to be very
very difficult
problem and the main main main result
the dis is that well this Min problem is
not that difficult in a sense that it's
actually we can reduce this to the the
mean cut problem actually so there a uh
uh the the main technical results in
this work is that we show that
um uh we can solve this m r uh normaliz
Min cut Problem by the reduction to poly
loock make many of them of the mean cut
and furthermore the technique also works
for the event Dynamic setting the
reduction can be done in also in the
dynamic basically the the main Dynamic
main R another result is that uh we can
maintain it dynamically under the weight
increase of the multiplic weight ofd
that framework and then the total time
is still the same as the dnamic M card
problem in the Tei and and conrat in the
uh that they provide for kcsm
problem so now I will get a little bit
uh technical on this part how to uh at
Le give give you a sense of how this can
be done on the static version uh
so now I will explain how to do this and
then I feel like it's uh very uh simple
trick so let's say that we focus on the
following problem I have a weighted
graph and then I want to out output this
normalized mean cut like in the linear
time and I want to Output one one plon
approximation so let's set some notation
a bit so first denote that opt is just
the optimal value of this mean r problem
normaliz mean cut problem and now let's
say that we can guess the value of this
up up to 1on so let's say that uh R this
is the guest value that is exactly one
plus one opt then I Define the weight
function in the following form to be the
Min for each Edge I just truncate that
if it's a exit uh row then I will just
set it to row otherwi I would just say
the noral way so basically just do we
tration and and by by row okay
and by doing this uh the key uh key
structural property is the following so
so take take the truncated weight and
look at the minimum
cut the the key claim is that you can
always find a free set of size k at most
K such that the value the normal life
value is one.on
approximation and Bas and then if this
is this LMA says that well is enough to
just solve mean cut and then you can
find the uh fre set automatically inside
this cut so given this Lama then the
algorithm is very simple just uh find
the Min cut find the the optimal uh F
star the the optimal fee cut and then
that that's the that's the deduction to
the main cut okay next I'm going to
explain uh why why we should expect this
M1 to to happen actually we I give a
full proof of of LMA one one question
yeah so this also works
zero
uh um if you Oh you mean like if if you
okay the question is if if if row is
exactly off then will it work yeah the
answer is yes so so it's actually the
mapping is exact yeah so this will also
solve the the Z problem in time um well
this
uh you mean the exact problem for the
minan roll for the
um at least I I I I I believe so yes yes
yes Al the mapping is exact but the the
way we guess we cannot get
the thank you for the question
um um okay so let's take a look oh yes
does it imply anything for the mean
introduction problem too or or not oh um
actually that's a great question because
uh there's a followup work that the
technique that we use here we we we
actually uh solved the uh open problem
in the interdiction problem as well
where there was an open problem that can
you get the FP task for the general
interdiction problem in terms out that
this technique can be kind of
generalized and then give the faster uh
in problem but it's different topic yeah
but thank you for the
question Yeah so basically this uh
transation and this one can be also used
to speed up the even the interdiction
problem um
yes
um
okay now let's take a look of the proof
of the LMA one and and this uh proof is
very simple I can even I WR the full
proof here so let's say that the LMA
says that uh you can find the the the
optimal set in the minimum cut with with
respect to the new weight right so let's
uh split into two claims the first claim
is the following that if
uh uh the
weight for any cut if you can find a
weight that is smaller than K1 plus L
opt then you can find the fre set that
that we are looking for and the second
claim is the following that the mean c
satisfy that that b the mean c will
respect to that
we okay so to be divine Two Step so
let's first prove the claim number two
which is very uh uh quite
straightforward so let's uh take a look
at the definition again so this is a
truncated weight so the weight is like
the minimum between the original weight
and the the threshold okay and let's say
that the optimal normalized mean cut is
of the form
dnf okay then we can first show that uh
uh the truncated weight is at most the
original weight here because by
definition of this truncated weight and
now by applying definition of the being
the optimal normalized Min cut this is
the same same as uh uh K minus F time
Epsilon this is just definition right
and
also and also the next line is look at
the next uh the weight of f we also know
that it's at most R time F because well
we we do trans it so it cannot go beyond
draw and that's by definition of bro is
like 1 one F now we just add them
together and then we we get this uh mean
that that that mean uh minimum
normalized cut is this satisfy like one
plon k op and therefore there has to be
a Min cut inside this way that is
smaller than uh one plon k op and then
we are done with claim number
two
now now we
you do the claim number one so now we
going to uh prove the first first
claim so let's uh F let's say I fix any
cut C satisfying the condition in claim
of one where that the the weight in the
Tran is at both one
plus opt let F be the set of heavy edges
in this set the heavy edes means that is
the weight is at least one on opt so I
Define is heavy otherwise I say
light now clearly this set of the heavy
edges has to be cannot have more than K
because otherwise the weight could be
far bigger than than this one part
op good so there so we know that there
are only at most K minus one which is
good for us
and what about the weight of the the cut
that is not heavy inside if it's not
heavy it means that uh when you uh
trunet then you don't you don't change
anything right and then you can write
this form the the second form the into
the uh the original weight and then
subtracted by the the the the trun
we and now for this part uh the you can
write Ro to be one one opt and therefore
[Music]
um
uh this is clear I guess I
don't I what I want to say is that if
you're following each each of this step
then the get the weight of C minus f is
going to be at most uh exactly K minus f
um this one person opt and then that's
the whole proof for of the
LMA
and yeah this uh at least gives you a
sense that the key thing is that you
just do the the the correct threshold
and then it basically become a minimum
cut problem and then so on but the
question for the dynamic version of the
problem is the following that uh maybe
the uh when you maintain the weight uh
when you do the multip weight update the
weight can keep increase and so on and
do you need to like set the threshold
differently and so on and the thing is
that the the the
and then to handle that case we're going
to use the batch version so let me let
me first let me first review the dynamic
version so now uh let's review the
multipl update framework for gon man
again now the algorithm looks like the
following first I initialize the weight
and somehow there's a way to initialize
it and the key point is that repeat the
following that compute approximate minan
row and then for each Ed inside I will
update the way so that's the the normal
framework and the we can keep increasing
and uh and so on for the today's for Pur
of today's talk I will not deal I will
not deal with how to do the Second Step
efficiently how to do the update the
weight efficiently I just focus on how
to maintain the minan roll efficiently
okay so there are two key issues that we
need to be uh aware of first how to
update this road and every time and then
second is uh how to identify the freet
quickly because the freet can be upsized
at to M so identify freet already takes
time even if I know the optimal cut for
you so first to handle the first first
part we're going to uh badge off into
the range of power of I or power of S1
plus S1 I because in in the same B then
you can use the same threshold and then
it's going to work out beside the same
same batch how do you uh how to do the
batching so this is exactly the
framework uh AO based uh framework of
the multi update so um this is at least
first uh know that I can tress off is by
fly show that you can do this kind of
batching for the multicommodity flow but
it can also be very general after Bing
so the framework is the following that
you also initialize the weight the same
way first compute the the Lambda which
is the minan row at the current weight
and repeat the following uh aox so you
need to do this only lock and oon square
aox
and how to do in each EPO then in each
compute the the mean minan r problem
which is CNF here and such that a
normaliz way is within this R and update
the we accordingly and repeat right and
then we do this until
um until the the Min roll uh uh has
increased by at least one Parton and
then we are and then this is the end of
and then we're going to and then this is
the end of the EPO and we start a new
EPO and it turns and then if you notice
that in this the same in the same EPO
then the same they have the same
threshold so you can just use the same
threshold throughout the EPO so this is
works very
nicely so now I'm going to focus on how
to speed up and Implement in this
AO now the the goal is to implement this
in time time of linear time uh plus the
number Cuts number cut of that output
inside the AO so if you can do this uh
then if you can do this implementation
then the total learning time would be
the of this format you just sum the
learning time over all the AO and then
you can show that it's going to be a
nearly linear running time because the
number EPO is only uh Lo n o square but
uh the number of the cuts that you
produce in each uh iteration that is
used is exactly the same as the number
itation in the NoNo version so you can
charge this to the number iteration
charge a number of cut to be the to be
uh nearly linear
okay so now
uh this I think is clear so now I'm
gonna uh tell you how to do this uh
uh uh to to to to do this uh reduction
to the dynamic minan cut basically we
uh for Simplicity here let's not worry
about the size of edges let's say that
the number edges is always bounded some
by by
poly and we're going to use the data
structure from K sh and condra to handle
the general loas so let's see how we how
we do this
um
so okay and
then okay before that there's also
another issue that you can uh Focus on
which is uh how to identify the best
freet quickly and then the key answer is
that well you do thresholding it will
automatically give this freet for you by
the thresholding so this can be
summarized uh the the the thresholding
is uh some can be sumed in this mapping
theorem in the following so fix uh a
threshold that is uh is 1 Lambda and den
note opt W to be the Min r optimal and
also the tranced weight here to be the
trated weight uh that we use now there
are two statement first of all say that
if
uh as long as the Min row is inside the
range then the minimum cut with respect
to that it's going to be inside a
certain
range so there are two uh two space one
space is a original weight and the
second state is on the Tran weight right
so as long as op inside this range then
the minan cut is going to be inside the
smaller range and if second the second
property is
that whenever you find a cut such that
the weight of uh the the trunc weight of
that cut is smaller than k k row that is
a good cut meaning that you can uh take
that cut together with the uh the free
edges defined by the set of edges that
is heavy mean meaning that you just take
the edges that is heavy but that is that
has a weight at at least row then you
can show that if you give this it's
automatically give you
a a good free Edge and then this is a
good uh approximate the uh free cut to
the Min R
problem
okay let's see how do uh how do we use
this to to
uh so basically the proof is very
similar to the static case so it's very
small modification then you will get it
so I will not present the proof here but
I will show you how to use this to uh to
to implement each EPO but
basically the outome is the following so
we initialize the weight uh the Euro
mean we we know the in let's say we we
at the starting of the EPO we initialize
the weight the Euro and then the goal
here is that we just run the we
initialize the dynamic algorithm of uh
by Chi and and Conrad with respect to
the the the trunc weight and the goal
here is the following that we just keep
listing uh the the the cut in this
range when because uh by the theorem if
we can list the cut by this range uh we
are in in good we will be able to find
the good cut and then we keep update the
we and and repeat so so basically it's
almost a almost a blackbox reduction
with small control that we need to be
careful so to to see how it works like
for example so
this
uh so let's say that at the first
iteration of is inside the range by the
range mapping theorem on the first
condition we know that there has to be
some cut inside this range in the second
space because there some cut then you
can find can use a dynamic data
structure to list this cut and then
because this cut in the this range uh
inside this range you can use the second
condition of the range mapping to say
that oh this cut you can also identify
the corresponding the free a set and
then you will get something that is
close to Optimal C automatically from
from the theorum and then when you do
the update updat the weight uh this
optimal value and the cut uh and the
weight of the cut also increases a bit
and then the the goal here just like
keep keep repeating listing this cut
until everything uh go out until uh
until the the cut in the second range go
out of this range go out the k k k row
and then uh this kind of finish of epoch
and then you can show that this simple
range mapping theorem will give you all
the all the ingredient that you need and
and and in here I hide all the details
about how to exactly uh implement the uh
the reduction but the high level of the
range mapping will will go along this
this this
way okay um so actually that's pretty
much uh all I want to say in in this
talk so I just want to conclude uh here
that um I I would love to also see more
systemtic theory of the file fast
approximation algorithm I would love to
see uh some uh more universal theory on
how to do fast LP or on on one more of
the comary optimization problem can we
develop fast routing algorithm can we do
the nearly linear time for to
es it's still unknown we don't know how
to do that in linear time and can we
solve LP for even broader cast on the
surv network design problem and we get
that faster we and even like can be Sol
the same LP here with high accuracy in
nearly linear time it's also very
interesting in my view this is because
uh many interactive bring a me high
accuracy s
yes so you just need one high accur
solution
or um every R yeah for routing so yes
I'm just asking like do you need to
solve one LP then or many many many okay
yeah itative loing means like you so
many
LP with that I would like to conclude my
talk have time for
questions okay then let's uh thanks s
try again
[Applause]